i'm so excited about the apple watch
ultra here it is this is the alpine loop
it's super cool
this is the trail
and over here my friend has the ocean
loop
this is all three of the new apple
watches this is the new apple watch se
the new apple watch ultra and the apple
watch series 8. let's take a look at
this apple watch ultra so as you can see
here it has the titanium case it has a
ceramic back it's a 49 millimeter
titanium in ceramic case you've got the
action button which is pretty impressive
so you can choose different actions
it will happen when you push that
so let's have that be a workout
there it is
started my workout
paused it
this is one of the new bands
this is the trail band and then over
here
we've got two other new bands the alpine
and the ocean four mountains